comprenez vous que karim benzema divisé
la france eric ccp reçu un coup de bol
c'est un sujet sociétal tout le monde en
a parlé
benzema qu'on ne connaisse le foot on
connaît sa carrière de karim qu'on
connaisse ce kid ap ou pas c'est vrai
que tout le monde a parlé de ça
comprenez vous vous allez nous lire dans
un instant a regardé hier didier car
appeler karim benzema attaquant
wissam ben yedder karim benzema kinsley
koeman ousmane dembélé olivier giroud au
poignet ou karim benzema divise la
france pour vous stéphane ravier vous
ils vous comprenez d'eiffarie bonsoir
oui moi je ne suis pas oui bonsoir je
suis pas venu ici pour contester les
talents de footballeur de karim benzema
tout le monde reconnaît même mon fils
est un grand supporter du joueur
d'accord je pourrais l'être aussi je le
suis aussi
mais en tant que responsable politique
moi je m'intéresse à l'homme à celui qui
déclare par exemple que sur le plan
sportif c'est la france mais sans doute
ce qu'il ce qui lui a permis d'être
devenu ce qu'il est aujourd'hui une
véritable pépite c'est grâce à la france
qu'il est devenu ce qu'il est et ce que
je constate c'est que n'a pas fait que
son coeur lui est en algérie
c'est ce qu'il a déclaré donc le
problème c'est que son coeur est en
algérie est ce que ces intérêts
manifestement sont en france ou en
europe en espagne
et ça je le regrette parce que si son
coeur est en algérie alors il doit
suivre son coeur la rue le coeur a ses
raisons que la raison ignore et bien le
coeur à ce jour et j'ai regardé si ce
que réparer et si son coeur est en
algérie
moi je l'invite à être cohérents et à
jouer pour l'équipe nationale algérienne
ah c'est ça être cohérent et ses
multiples déclarations et notamment au
lendemain de sa non sélection en équipe
de france par les ja didier deschamps il
avait accusé didier deschamps de céder à
la partie raciste qui serait qu'ils
seraient en france donc ils insultent le
sélectionneur en tout cas ils le
soupçonnent de céder à ce qui serait un
racisme dans ce pays alors que ce pays
lui a tout donné
à défaut d'avoir la reconnaissance du
coeur il pourrait au moins avoir la
reconnaissance du ventre sais même pas
si vous parlez de la marseillaise savez
il ya des grands joueurs comme si dan
mais j'attends toujours les mêmes
arguments sous-entendant que benzema
n'aime pas la france mais c'est pas vrai
vous oubliez dire par exemple que c'est
un exemple de patriotisme en termes de
fiscalité par exemple c'est un des rares
grands sportifs à tient à payer ses
impôts en france
et moi j'aime social pour le droit
censitaire alors vous êtes pour leur est
permis quand je dis que c'est un exemple
en terme de quatre utilise la
nationalité un an à partir de l'impôt
mon nom je dis que vous n'aimez pas le
nom vous dit qu'il n'est pas là
franchement ça vous arrange les laisser
truc c'est le coeur c'est pas simplement
porter le maillot de l'équipe de france
quand vous portez le maillot de l'équipe
de france vous représentez la france
d'accord on va voir je pense une
attitude qui démontre son attachement à
la france et à ses traditions à son
histoire à son peuple
or karim benzema lui a déclaré je
personne ne le conteste ici car tout le
monde le sait que son coin que son coeur
n'est pas du côté de la france il est du
côté de l'algérie et la dronne et mes
amis
mais il faut être cohérent si le coeur
de de karim benzema est en algérie il a
tout le loisir algérienne d'abord gilles
verdez juste pour revenir sur cette
affaire ils se sont parlés a compté nous
comment ça s'est fait comme mon calme
est revenu pour les téléspectateurs
en fait didier deschamps depuis le mois
de mars était un peu inquiet au niveau
de son effectif et des attaquants dont
qui s'est dit pourquoi pas benzema
il en parle à noël le graet ya un mois
et demi noël le graet lui dit c'est une
très bonne idée je la soutiens et donc
ils se sont appelés se sont vus alors
pour le moment c'était fin avril il
garde le lieu secret ils se sont vus
tous les deux et en voyant benzema
deschamps a vu que benzema était prêt à
revenir qu'il ne poserait pas de
problèmes qu'il avait changé que c'était
un grand joueur et il s'est dit je le
veux et à ce moment là tous les feux
sont au vert
et benzema lui même lui a dit c'est pour
ça que je vous réponds directement
monsieur j'aime le maillot de l'équipe
de france je veux porter ce maillot de
l'équipe de france je n'ai pu porter
depuis 2015
je suis prêt omar da fonseca pour vous
c'est une bonne nouvelle et puis vous
comprenez des gens qui qui voilà qui
essaient de rose sur faire ressurgir pas
des histoires des vieilles polémiques
ces peines ne sont pas qu'avant histoire
d'abord je pense que c'est un moment où
il faut le valoriser
parce que je trouve que c'est un peu la
réconciliation ni âme pardon une entente
une communication pour les temps qui
courent dosez transhumants qui a eu à un
moment donné nos divergences nos
différents supporte à la limite ça nous
est tous arrivé à un moment donné des
s'est fâché avec un ami depuis un
certain temps quelques années notre
famille c'est c'est vraiment le courage
il ajouté
allez y allez travers or aussi je vais
me permettront dire l'histoire des limes
vous savez et moi ça fait 40 ans presque
40 ans mais je serai ici je suis né en
argentine et et je mets chauds considère
la france est le meilleur pays du monde
mais j'ai des enfants et des petits
enfants et les vieux démons parce que
même à une plainte des détails
moi j'adore par tous et toutes les
belles choses qu'on a ici
or et je ne chante pas la marseillaise
on dirait que la france et chez ses amis
du lac tonelli vous savez déjà en
espagne mettant il n'ya pas des paroles
donc il sait pas léser les jouets a
bondi de rational moi je vous ai pas
parlé d'une nationale un moment donné on
a dix huit quotidiens de karim benzema
mais pour vous dire que vous employez le
moqueur on a tous un racing lien je sais
pas les bretons qui sont le coeur en
bretagne alors qu'ils allaient se
détacher la vérité moi mes parents ils
sont de suède
j'ai la tête à parier que les pouilles à
stockholm
ça ne divise pas au contraire je trouve
que encore une fois j'étais ce matin
dans une pour la fondation n'est pas
récemment il y avait plein d'enfants et
tout le monde était content mais vous
allez voir que ce soit que dans l'esprit
football ou en dehors
on va voir parce que malgré ce qu'on
peut dire le sport en général il est
encore une fois je trouve que l'entente
décès de monsieur véhicule
la valeur que l'on peut avoir une
cohésion à travers le sport le football
et lots fait avec et benzema puis soir
intégré c'est pour unir pour nous
montrer encore j'ai regardé xavier
bertrand qui était ce matin sur ses news
aviez
qui a presque supplié joueurs de chanter
la marseillaise à une seconde chance qui
lui est offerte par didier deschamps
alors qu'il saisisse la main tendue il a
dit qu'il était fier de porter le
maillot qu'il se montre à la hauteur de
la confiance que lui témoigne didier
deschamps c'est à dire qu'ils soient à
la hauteur qu'il chante la marseillaise
moi j'aime bien chanter la marseillaise
j'aime bien qu'on l'entende et j'aime
bien les joueurs chanter la marseillaise
mais encore une fois à se placer sur le
terrain du foot faisons confiance à des
chants et que benzema se montre à la
hauteur de la confiance de deschamps
seulement foot
il suffit pas de porter le maillot il
faut porter le drapeau il est algérien
que ce sont des anciennes
il faut pardonner moi je suis prêt à
pardonner mais il faut qu' il faut que
karim benzema demande pardon il a mis sa
fille à madrid dans une école française
qu'il veut il l'a dit il veut lui
apprendre sa culture voilà l'enjeu
combien coûtera sont faits en france une
équipe venue apprendre ces valeurs on
lui reproche de passer à ces êtres
français parce qu'ils aiment l'algérie
mais on marche sur la tête alors oui il
a reconnu l'excellence de la de
l'instruction du nucléaire l'a privée
française
ça ne fait pas de lui un amoureux de la
france sanef the river qui est attachée
à son histoire à ses traditions et
qu'ils veulent et tranquille je rappelle
qu en 2020 c'est pas si vieux 2020 il
allait bien il a leaké un tweet d'un
champion de mma certains acabit voilà
qui a insulté le président de la
république et qui en appelait à la
punition divine est au châtiment
d'appuis ce mission divine envers tous
ceux qui insultent ferait le prophète
jeu là ça ce monsieur la responsabilité
de ceux de son tweet mais karim benzema
a leaké ce tweet et il a pas retiré ce
laïc c'est aussi une manière de ce une
manière de se séparer de la france parce
que c'est pas notre culture sachez
madame ce n'est pas notre culture c'est
ça la réalité encore actuelle de karim
benzema
j'ai donné je me permets de
je sais là franchement c'est ignoble ce
que vaut des salaires comme en fait non
soyez clair soyez clair on voulait
reproché de s'appeler benzema ou les
reprocher voulez mais si mais si vous
lui reprochez des pc il avoue lui
reprocher d'avoir des racines
algériennes dont il est fier et il a
aussi le coeur français toutes ces
sociétés ont aidé à toutes ces sociétés
en france ils avaient tous ses amis à
lyon toutes ces actions qui tue et le
monsieur s'est tendu car il a vécu dans
la foi il avait le coeur grenadine
[Rires]
en fait vous êtes endettés ne sais pas
ce que vous êtes boutique de votre fonds
de commerce et la fracture est en fait
ça vous emmerde ont ils créent leur
nature c'est pas du tout avec son
personnage public landais l'oubli pour
ces policiers deschamps lui doit donner
l'exemple à la jeune alésien bombe
atomique
non mais j'ai rien contre vous mais
c'est vrai que au rassemblement national
vous êtes tous
il parle beaucoup c'est un mois et par
le jeu marseillais s'est pas défaussé
grand oui les gens on va chercher didier
deschamps fait un pas lui tend la main
il ya un dialogue il ya une
réconciliation vous êtes vous serez pas
que c'est plutôt un bon signe justement
pour l'instant je ne vois là même tendu
que que le seul de didier deschamps je
ne vais pas vous avez vous savez le
retire cela et que de ce fameux tweet y
manque de têtes qui vous soutient
je demande je demande à karim benzema de
s'excuser auprès d'olivier giroud qui
l'a insulté je demande aux ferries
benzema de s'excuser auprès des français
qui là qu'il a insulté en les qualifiant
de raciste
je demande à karim benzema de s'excuser
pourrait avoir été l'entremetteur entre
des voyous lyonnais et et mathieu
valbuena dans cette affaire risque de la
sextape
je lui demande de s'excuser vous savez
présumé innocent je suis magnanime je
suis prêt à pardonner on peut aussi
demander partir du moment où d'ailleurs
beaucoup et demande également à eric
meyer de pardonner à cet égard des mails
et instrumentalisé par des partis
politiques
insupportable en a fait un objet
politique aux îles s'il s'est excusé
quel est le problème pour lui de revenir
en équilibre sans fin et qu'il était là
il ne serait pas s'est elle amusée mme
d'armement présenteriez la preuve aux
toiles beaucoup de la marseillaise
regarder on a retrouvé
on a retrouvé d'autres joueurs qui ne
chantait pas la marseillaise avait et
qui sait c'est qu'on veut passer et puis
bon ces deux joueurs on adore cinédit
d'années michel platini
ça me choque tout
[Musique]
s'il était blanc qui chantait pas ça
posait pas un problème s'il était un peu
de couleur et qui chantait pas se poser
un problème
c'est un problème si on fait quoi en
fait j'avais chanté et j'ai dit pourquoi
je la chanterai pas jeu s'anime de
guérir moi j'allais jouer au football
si j'allais reyer j'ai arrêté de chanter
et jouer au football j'ai chanté par la
dialyse ne s'est pas une revue un match
de foot c'est pas une revue militaire et
pour quelles raisons mais je sais des
choses des divertissements champions
comme lynam au hasard comme l'hymne
algérien
c'est un chant guerrier et qui appelle
qui appellent à la haine de la france
est citée dans l'hymne national algérien
personnes en fait le grief aux algériens
c'est au niveau national ça fait partie
de notre histoire qu'on doit transmettre
et là par exemple sans appel par sms que
vous répondez monsieur à platini je
regrette qu'il n'ait pas chanté l'hymne
à cette houle avons greffé je le
regrette aussi pour benzema à la
différence la différence entre les deux
c'est que si michel platini ne chantait
pas il restait jeudi reste aux ics
concentré moi j'ai vu karim benzema avec
comment s'appelle-t-il ce marseillais
déjà se fendre la poire rigolé pendant
l'hymne national craché
nationale a dit que ses défauts je vois
un karim benzema qui se fout de l'hymne
national qui se met en retrait mais qui
se moque de nos climats nationale qui
quelque part le rejette et ça plus
appuyé sans plus à karim benzema a
peut-être oublié qu'au delà d'être un
sportif il est devenu une star
internationale des millions de jeunes et
de jeunes français suivent le suivent le
vénère justin long et lorsqu'ils jouent
pas ou par des déclarations ils
influencent la jeunesse française la
sortie tout est aujourd'hui vous la
détestez vous savez les grêlés qu'il est
aujourd'hui ses responsabilités et donc
non mais elle est entachée par des
déclarations parfois d'ailleurs je
regardais les fractures et je vous dit
vous n'êtes que sur des idées reçues sur
thr vous avez parlé de l'année qui
chantait pas la marseillaise y en a
plein d'autres qui chantent pas la
marseillaise
karim aujourd'hui karim da il est
irréprochable s'est déclarée valide les
sportives me suis arrêté
que c'est dans la sphère valbuena c'est
insulte au peuple français est qu'il est
rapide ouvert est-ce que je les ai
inventées arrêtez vous êtes à limiter
les zones l'action des condamnés voilà
on sait vous êtes geek dont est né voici
un fait imaginez vous car vous avez
parlé à votre fils est ce qu on peut
imaginer que votre fils avec l'apport de
benzema
quelqu'un qui va jouer qui est unanime
et reconnu il faut le dire aussi que
c'est un taux la deux le fait qu'il
revienne internationalement tout le
monde ils ont mis en fonctionnement et
de réconcilier m'en serais aussi mais là
où il va le prouver
voilà donc essayons d d d d aller vers
le bonheur vous allez on a une
possibilité encore une fois parce que ça
existe dans le football
chaque fois que la france y gagne on
sait revenir en europe et que la maison
excuses hockey a toujours la pression
essayons d'ouvrir d'avoir le chacun a
fait la seule je vous ai cola pour
qu'ils s'excusent auprès de vous par
exemple que c'était qui s'est toujours
échangé contre didier deschamps sait que
derrière il a un comportement vous
croyez vous à la seconde chance ou pas
ou vous condamnez on a tous les deux on
avait tout le monde et qui font que des
jeunes changent dès demain vous ne
donnez pas de seconde chance ce que je
vois c'est que monsieur benzema cumul
cumule les les déclarations les plus
nomades arabes leur dire monsieur ce
n'est pas simplement la sphère de
l'hymne national qu'il ne chante pas
c'est le fait qu'ils rigolent pendant
l'hymne national
il qualifie les français de raciste
c'est le fait qu'il dise moi mon coeur
il est en algérie pas en france c'est
une succession est quand même trop de
points c'est une ligne
il agit c'était quelqu'un de
relativement des passionnés devant clés
dessus de moi
moi je fais confiance à didier deschamps
que les gènes de la protection des choix
attendent maintenant dessinée qu'il faut
pendre benzema est bien très bien je lui
fait confiance même si j'avais tous mes
choquant quand on me dit que sans nom à
lui deschamps était trop français et
quand on avait bien mis de l'huile sur
le feu donc moi tu aimes didier lescos
descendu en séance
deschamps lui fait confiance donc moi
aussi maintenant la question c'est est
ce que vous comprenez qu'il divise
oui je comprends que benzema puisse
diviser mais pas encore pardonné
psychologiquement et que voilà et puis
tant mieux tant mieux si la suite donnée
donc maintenant pardonnez-moi sur l'île
sur ligne c'est vrai que globalement moi
je me souviens d'un match portugal
france et je fais pas de distinguer la
nécro les gens chanter leur hymne avec
beaucoup de fierté et d'enthousiasmé
nous du côté français tout le monde est
debout dit didier deschamps
monsieur vous fait un procès d'intention
à karim benzema c'est tout ce que vous
faites défaut d'idées faut parler de la
peur de la sec les baies les bras jugé
c'est une accumulation de poncifs vous
reprenez impulsé vous réécrivez une
histoire fait l'histoire de karim
benzema rien mais aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui 9 français sur 10 sont
heureux de son retour
réjouissez vous aurez choisi mais il est
clivant benzema réjouissez-vous toc en
français s'il vous plaît oui à 49%
voilà les oiseaux à 51 cents à 90 % il
vous parle pas des emplois fictifs du
rassemblement national
où nous attend ne parle pas de vos
emplois fictifs du rapport mais le
rapport parle de valbuena ou voulez vous
sortez vos arrières
ils ont sorti les affaires ont été
recensées accuse souvent et simplement
dire vive l'algerie cuisine de l'algérie
le soin de ceux des femmes
tout en moi que ce soit le tribunal vive
l'algérie vive l'algerie oui tribune
vive l'algérie
[Applaudissements]